[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact normally when
you think of flowers we picture
something in small delicate and fragrant
those are probably not the words you'd
use to describe a flower frown growing
in the rainforests of Sumatra it's known
as the titan arum this giant flower can
take between seven to ten years to
produce its first bloom when it does
bloom you'll know it the flower looks
like an 8 foot long loaf of French bread
protruding straight up from a deep
burgundy and green pleated skirt that
surrounds the base one record-breaking
specimen in a botanical garden in New
Hampshire at a central spike more than
10 feet high and leaves 13 feet around
and this plant is heavy too with some
specimens weighing in at over 300 pounds
the titan arum is also known as the
corpse flower because when it does bloom
it emits a sickening smell some have
described the odour as a cross between
dirty socks garlic Limburger cheese and
rotten fish and I bet you're glad you're
being protected by radio right now the
plant puts off a rotten smell for about
48 hours to attract flies and beetles
that help pollinate it the corpse flower
is also one of the only plants that can
generate its own heat through a chemical
reaction reaching 98 degrees when in
full bloom it's hard to imagine such a
large majestic flower that stinks
the Bible says Satan's counterfeits
often work the same way stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 invites you to
call in talk about the Word of God the
most important book my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends pastor Doug as usual
let's start the program with prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you for the
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study together we want to ask
your blessing upon this program be with
those who are listening Lord guide us
into a clear understanding of the Bible
for we ask this in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor you open the program but
talking about a remarkable flower that
first of all it's big it's looking at a
picture of it online little early
actually there was one occasion when I
was a in DC and this particular plant
was flowering there at one of the
museums and people formed a long line to
go in and look at it wasn't smelling by
the time we made it in but it's quite
impressive it is a big flower and yet
the strange thing about it is it's got
this terrible smell that is irresistible
to certain bugs and flies yeah it's the
opposite of the kind of flower that
would attract a butterfly looking for a
fragrance this one is it's supposed to
imitate the the stench of carrion and
that's also they suspect that it's made
where it also puts off heat like
something decomposing
so it's hot it's red in the middle and
it stinks and flies just love it of
course they come disappointed they don't
find anything they're deceived into
coming but in the process they are used
by the flower to pollinate and but it's
deceptive because when you look at the
flower from the distance it's you know
got a big yellow stalk coming out of
that red skirt and it's majestic looking
you get close and you take a whiff
I actually saw YouTube a show people's
faces it may have been the one there at
the Botanical Gardens in Washington DC
showed all these people lined up coming
to see the flower and they get close and
they just turn up their noses but it
only makes that terrible smell for a
little while anyway it's you know here
you get a flower is masquerading as a
flower but it really stinks and in the
Bible Jesus warns that the devil will
sometimes look like a sheep but he's
really a wolf and so many of the
deceptions that the devil has in the
Bible he counterfeit something good and
he replaces it with something dangerous
or deadly or deceptive and that's his
practice The Devil's got a counterfeit
for love he's got a counterfeit for the
gift of tongues the devil has a
counterfeit baptism so you can name just
about any doctrine and he's taken all
these various truths and he's got a
counterfeit and it'll look good from a
distance but on closer investigation it
doesn't smell right doesn't pass the
smell test as they say and maybe you'd
like to understand better and what some
of these counterfeits are and how you
can spot them friends we have a free
offer tonight for you on that subject we
have a book that's entitled Satan's
confusing counterfeits and this is a
free offer for anyone who will call and
ask the phone line to call for this free
offer eight hundred eight thirty five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called Satan's confusing
counterfeits that number again is 883
five six seven four seven and asked for
the book Satan's confusing canif it's in
France if you didn't know we're also
streaming live this evening on Facebook
on the amazing facts Facebook page and I
think pass it on your page yeah life is
great
so we're joining us on Facebook and if
you
a Bible question I want to give us a
call here the number to call is 804 6 3
7 2 97 and that'll bring your call
writing here to the studio first caller
that we have this evening is Stephanie
listening in New Mexico Stephanie
welcome to the program hi thank you
thank you and your question tonight ok
my question comes out of James 3 6 3 6
and 8 where it talks about the tongue is
a fire of iniquity how it defiles the
whole body and then 8 where it says no
man can tame the tongue it son really
evil full of deadly poison so I struggle
with some anger bitterness wrath that
I'm working on and so my tongue is not
tamed at all and I pray all the time and
we came across the scripture at church
today and so what is the answer to
painting the tongue Matthew chapter 12
Jesus said out of the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks and as you
mentioned you know if you're struggling
with anger it's gonna be hard to repress
that and not to voice the the anger the
bitterness or whatever you're going
through it requires really a
transformation of the heart and you know
when when we're born again no man can
tame the tongue but the Lord can change
our hearts and that ends up changing our
words and it is very important for us to
you know pray that God will help us get
victory over our words because in
Matthew 12 jesus also said that in the
judgment will give an account for every
idle word that we speak for you by our
words you'll be condemned and by your
words you'll be justified and of course
all of us have said things we shouldn't
say and all of us need to ask that God
will forgive us for reckless speaking
but you know when we get a new heart we
then pray the Lord will help us to say
those things that are positive good pure
kind and it may not happen overnight but
as our hearts are transformed our words
change just a very quick in kind of a
simplistic illustration
before I was a Christian I you know had
a very foul mouth you know with the you
know the druggies I was hanging out with
back in those days you know we just used
all the first words and I probably still
know them all but once the Lord got
ahold of my heart I began to feel you
know Jesus wouldn't talk like that and I
want to follow Jesus and little by
little I'd catch myself the Holy Spirit
would just stop me when I was about to
say one of those words or I'd say it
then I feel so bad I want to do it
anymore and you know I don't have that
problem anymore the Lord changed my
heart he changed my tongue and it's not
that there isn't so room for growth but
I've just witnessed firsthand when God
changes your heart it can change your
words okay that's awesome
the other resource on anger or taming
the tongue anything like that we do
bitterness anything like that yeah we
have a little book that I think you'll
find very interesting called
tips for resisting temptation and deals
with those principles of a change of
heart how to control one's temper or
attitude it'll it'll be in there it'll
address that and we'll be happy to send
that to you for free again the book is
called tips for resisting temptation and
the number to call for that is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven now wait a minute that's the
number here to the studio you just call
that number but the number for our
resource is 800 eight three five six
seven four seven you know there's
another book you can also read for free
online Stephanie and it's specifically
on the subject of speaking and it's
called tiny troublemakers oh yeah that's
a good one candy talks about when you
talked about if you wrestle with gossip
but it'll have some of the same verses
that we talked about you can read that
for free at the amazing facts or both
books are free but you can read that one
right now for free at the amazing facts
website you just type in title tiny
troublemaker and you type in Joe Cruz
it'll probably pull it up right away
thank you appreciate your call next
caller that we have is Jerry listening
in Oregon Jerry welcome to the program
thank you pastors Ross and Bachelor
about a year ago I asked question about
a white lie or a justified lie and
pastor Doug said a lie
Alai basically categorically and I
realize that in Revelation that says all
Liars are excluded from the holy city
but I was just rereading Exodus 1 and I
became an account were Pharaoh ordered
two midwives to kill all the baby boys
and they didn't do it and then Beryl
asked him why they didn't do it and they
responded because Hebrew women are more
vigorous and they give birth before we
can get there which was a lie basically
and then in chapter 20 verse 20th
chapter 1 it says so God was kind to the
midwives and the people increased and
became even more numerous now
that technically was a lie but obviously
it was a justified lie so why would god
bless him because it seems like when the
Lord would be bending his own rules now
well to an extent I mean it you know he
obviously one is not supposed to kill
children either but again they were put
in a difficult position and they gave a
you know offered a justified lie you
know my guess is it's interesting you
would ask this because I read that verse
this week and I do the same thing pastor
Doug I I hear things and I just study
them a couple days before it is happened
so many times but that's a digression
yeah no it's okay it's amazing how the
Lord does that but you know I thought
about that this week and in the answer
the ladies gave because here they are
the midwives for this nation of Israel
you read in Exodus it says god bless
them and they increased greatly I think
two or three times as they multiplied
very greatly so much so the Egyptians
are saying what are we gonna do these
guys are just you know they're becoming
so numerous those midwives two midwives
and it names them it's very unusual that
it actually gives their names and it
says God bless them they're probably
were times when they got there and the
baby was already born and so I think
maybe they were citing a couple of cases
where it was true that they got there
before they were you know the babies
were already born by the time I got
there I'm sure that was a partial truth
so I would agree with you that
they also had just decided we are not
gonna kill these babies and you know the
Lord winks at our ignorant sometimes
it's like he blessed Rahab
when she lied and said all the
messengers went out the gate you better
run after him what she did was a
bold-faced lie but you know she was a
pagan she is doing the best she could
and with those midwives you know the
Israelites in Egypt they were not
obeying all of God's commandments and I
think he winked at their ignorance
doesn't mean that God blesses lying it
just means that he meets people where
they're at they were frightened they
didn't want to die they didn't want to
hurt neither babies and so God bless
them but yeah God always wants us to
tell the truth on a similar note
supposing I approach you and I say
pastor Doug I'd like to show you a
picture of my granddaughter she's a
beautiful child
I swear someday she's gonna me Miss
America and I tell you the picture and
you think well this little girl's gonna
have to go to quite a metamorphosis I
mean you're probably going to say yes
she's a beautiful girl that's an unfair
question can we go to the next caller
please yeah you know that is something
that when you're a pastor and you're at
the door you know frequently people come
out and they'll say here's our new baby
and you look at some of the babies are
just adorable I guess they're all
adorable to the mothers and some are
better-looking than others I think we'll
all admit but boy you're in trouble if
you say anything other than that's a
beautiful baby so you know you got us
there that I think sometimes just out of
graciousness we speak with a little bit
of hyperbole and we tell everybody all
your kids are adorable and so forth and
that's sort of just considered good
manners but you're right if you you're
probably not going to get very far in
life if you tell everybody everything
you think about them you know what I
mean the example example I too cited the
two examples I cited there was no
malicious intent
yeah and that's right I still think
Christians should always be honest I
think you need to be kind and there are
times when you don't say everything
you're thinking even Christ said to the
disciples there's many things I have to
say to you but you cannot bear them now
in other words you said you just it's
like you don't tell a five-year-old
everything about the birds and the bees
because they just can't handle it at
that age so you know not saying
everything you know there's biblical
reasons for that because timing is
important but I don't think we should
ever be dishonest or misleading we
should be transparent and just pray for
diplomacy if you see an ugly baby hey
thank you very much for your question
and that's a good question that Mick
Foley's Gina listening in Ohio Gina
welcome to the program are you good
I have a question about the Sabbath I've
always felt really guilty about because
when you always have your utilities on
your gas or electric there's no way to
set them off mm-hmm and I was really bad
because I mean I'm making somebody work
you know at these companies is there
anything biblically that says that I
mean heat out you know tells us not to
work or make anybody else work but like
if I feel guilty about
yeah will that is a good practical
question I think you know all of us
would agree that we're thankful that on
the Sabbath day our phones are working
and power is still on in the house and
and we know there's people out there
that are operating those services Jesus
one time someone said Lord I you know I
want to follow you but first I've got to
bury my father and Jesus said something
a little disturbing he said let the dead
bury the dead you follow me we can't
control what everybody does and you know
there are going to be people that will
be doing that they don't know the Lord
they don't let them do it and but we
shouldn't be doing it
I don't know if that makes sense you
know I think first of all if let's just
say you turn off all the power you
disconnect the gas for 24 hours well
that have any impact upon the people
that are actually working in the
utilities getting power and gas to
hundreds of homes throughout the city
it's gonna make no it's not gonna make
any difference to them they're still
gonna be doing their job so you know
it's a little different if you are
hiring someone specifically to come
and hook up your power on the Sabbath
that's a little different but here's
someone that's doing a job they're gonna
be doing it whether you use the power or
you don't use the power it's kind of out
of your control it's out of your yeah
direction in the Sabbath commandment
says that in your house within your
gates yeah you know we're really only
able to control what happens within our
gates and you know if you own the power
company that might be different every
difference yes and we want to talk to
you about something else if you own the
power company all right well thank you
very much I appreciate thank you
appreciate your question next photo that
we have is Michael listening in Michigan
Michael welcome to the program
hey guys can you hear me loud and clear
awesome I figured he could I just wanted
to make sure I am you know because of
his mom headphones I have um I know I
called last week about evil spirits but
is there the question I have about other
denominations there's a Bible
specifically say that all meaning you
know Catholics or whatever every
denomination will be in heaven like
where are the Bible texts for that
because that's a lot of people say that
you know that Adventists are not the
only ones going ahead and I said can't
wants people have tell those people
saying that to me and just say well I
don't know what the Bible verses are but
I heard that everything elimination
whooping has and I'm like well okay let
me yeah let me back let me just back up
to restate the question a little bit and
if you've got your radio on in the
background you may want to turn that
down because we're getting feedback from
that I don't think I hope there aren't
people out there that think only one
denomination is going to be in heaven
Jesus is pretty clear that there are
people who were born Jewish that aren't
going to be saved just because they're
Jewish you know he said those who don't
follow the truth they're children of the
devil's doesn't matter what denomination
you're in and there are people in the
church that are gonna be in heaven the
Lord said other sheep I have that are
not of this fold them all so I must call
and there will be one fold and one
Shepherd I think that's John chapter 10
so
you know there's gonna there's good
people if they're living up to the
scriptural truth that they have you know
God doesn't judge us by what we don't
know another way I might say that
there'll be people in heaven like King
David and Solomon that had you know
scores of wives well we know that's
wrong it's not true that you should have
that many wives there'll be people in
heaven that maybe didn't understand what
the Bible says about clean and unclean
food well they didn't know got a winks
at their ignorance the Bible says now he
commands everyone to repent when you
know the truth Hebrews chapter 10 says
sin is knowing to do good and not doing
it and so God is not looking on
denominational roles to see who is saved
he's looking at are we living up to the
light that he's giving us so you know
we've got a book that I think helps
answer that it's called search for the
true church we're Baptists send it to
anybody who calls and asked what are the
biblical characteristics that are given
for God's people nowadays I will be
happy to send that to you the number to
call these eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book called to search for the
true church and that's holy that we have
is let's see we've got Vernon listening
in New York
Vernon welcome to the program yeah you
guys doing good thanks for calling thank
you I've asked this question before and
never got a good solid answer to this
question so I will present this to both
of you when it comes to God he's
omniscient he has ability of omnipresent
and he's omnipotent am I correct on
those three things yes okay sin first
started in heaven and not on earth am I
correct in that yes okay now let's go
down to the earth when God had created
Adam and Eve he put four four tree in
the garden called the tree of
good and evil this is my question then I
hang up to hear your answer since God
has these three attributes if that tree
wasn't there there would be no sin on
earth nor Christ had to come to down the
cross and people on the earth would live
forever because we know Satan came down
and tempted Eve and he bought off the
fruits or a husband and God had to bring
judgment upon all three for the sin that
was committed so here's my question why
did God put that tree there and should
not that tree had not been there have a
nice day all right hey thank you very
much for your question well when the
tree was placed in the garden the tree
was actually there to limit the ways
that Satan could access this new world
and God told Adam and Eve he said look
you know there's been a rebellion in the
universe and one of the highest of our
creations has chosen a way of
selfishness and sin and he is going
through the universe he's got limited
access to recruit people to his side do
not go to this tree this is a forbidden
tree and Adam and Eve were warned that
that tree might be the gateway to evil
coming into the lives in order for God
to give all of his creatures freedom he
had to give them the opportunity to make
a decision
so really the tree where if the tree
wasn't here one and it kept the devil
from coming into our world and tempting
Adam and Eve it would have been on some
other ground but God just restricted he
said look I'm gonna give you one
restriction and it's just this tree and
it's the only place where the Satan is
going to be able to access this world to
tempt and so yeah God made all of his
creatures free and in order to really be
free and to choose to love him we have
to have the opportunity to make a choice
so he gave them that opportunity you
know you would really enjoy a DVD that
we produce that goes into more detail
talking about where did sin come from
and and you know what if God had done
things differently what would have
happened
it's called cosmic
conflict I think you can just YouTube
cosmic conflict or go to the amazing
facts YouTube channel and you can watch
the whole thing for free right there
online I mixed for that we have these
Dennis listening in Vacaville Dennis
welcome to the program thank you very
much and thank you for being there to
help all of us well it's a blessing we
got about four minutes or three minutes
before the break Dennis so let's get
right to your question as god has the
foresight and prophesied and foretold of
endtime signs I was wondering are there
any verses that nearly describe some of
these modern things that we do people
flying in the air in airplanes like
birds or flying around the earth or
traveling to the moon and or such a
thing as nuclear bombs wiping out whole
cities well let me give you a couple of
verses that have been pointed to in well
Daniel chapter 12 Daniel says many will
run to and fro and knowledge will
increase that's a pretty broad statement
but he's talking about people going to
and fro they already went to and fro in
his day but they did it on horseback now
they're going to and fro people travel
you know hundreds of miles thousands of
miles from the place of their birth they
didn't used to do that people often
never went more than 50 miles from their
birthplace in their entire life mm-hmm
and so that was one thing and he says
knowledge will increase he didn't say
wisdom would increase because people
aren't really much wiser today than they
used to be but knowledge and technology
has increased greatly and you know Jesus
said except those days be shortened no
flesh would be saved implying that man
would have the ability to destroy
himself and I forget pastor Ross and in
Revelation is at chapter 11 where it
says God will destroy those that destroy
the earth yeah and so man did not have
the ability to destroy the earth when
John wrote the book of Revelation but
man certainly has the technology and the
ability through chemicals pollution
nuclear weapons to destroy the earth now
so that's just a handful but it
sounds to me brother like he'd really
enjoy our study guide talking about the
second coming and it goes into some of
the signs of the second coming as well
and that's called the ultimate
deliverance the Oldham of deliverance
will be able to send it to anybody who
calls and asks the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can answer the
study guide called the ultimate
deliverance all about the second coming
and it talks about signs that relate to
the second coming absolutely
now we're gonna be taking a break in
just a moment
Pastor also now we're gonna tell you
before we go to the break that if you've
not seen it before for the students out
there that enjoy Bible study there is a
website called the Bible history comm
and it has a Bible timeline I think it's
one of the more popular Bible timelines
you'll find on the internet and you can
look at the scope all the way from
creation you can see where the major
events occurred and track all the way
from creation down through up to the
second coming not that we don't set a
date for that but you know which shows
that it's next on the calendar so just
check out Bible history calm and again
want to tell you we have lines open if
you give us a call eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven I want to
greet again our friends that are
watching on Facebook you can join them
if you are curious what it looks like
here in the studio that's simply amazing
facts Facebook page we're gonna be back
in just a few months
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing fact
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
you on the air ok sweet Daniel 9:25
where it says now therefore and
understand o therefore and understand
that from the going forth of the
commandment to restore and to build
Jerusalem unto the Messiah the Prince
shall be so many weeks my understanding
is that this prophecy started in Ezra
chapter 7 with the decree of artaxerxes
but my question was why did not start in
Azhar chapter 1 and said it was a decree
of Cyrus with the decree of Cyrus where
Cyrus is telling us or us to basically
go
when build the temple so yeah that's a
confession and there is an answer the
first decree there were actually three
decrease the first decree that was given
allowed the Jews to go back and start
rebuilding the temple their work was
stopped and so the same decree was given
again to kind of just allow them through
Darius to continue finishing the temple
but it was the third decree of
artaxerxes in 457 BC which allowed them
to rebuild Jerusalem and that involved
building a wall around the city and if
you look in verse 25 know therefore and
understand that from the going forth of
the commandment to restore and build
Jerusalem and that was really the third
decree that allowed them to actually
rebuild the city in the wall and yeah
the last part of the verse says and the
street in the wall will be built again
in trouble as times it specifies okay
and of course the whole book of Nehemiah
is about rebuilding the wall huh
awesome thank you all right hey good
question now we've got a whole study on
Daniel 9 that this is outstanding would
that be right on time yes God set the
date for the judgment we get two lessons
there I think both are good they both
touch on Daniel 9 but let me give you
both you can just call and answer them
we'll be able to send it to you the one
study guide deals with right on time
which deals with Daniel 9 and the other
one is God set a date for the judgment
we'll be able to send those two studies
to anybody who asks the number is 883
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the study guide dealing with Daniel
chapter 9 it's God set a date for the
judgment and right on time or the names
of the two lessons our next corner that
we have is Doug listening in Minnesota
Doug welcome to the program I have a
question about how God is going to deal
with the wicked after the after the
thousand year period yeah well if you
read in Revelation 20 that it tells us
about the wicked is they surround the
beloved city as if they're going to
attack it and by the way what you find
in Revelation 20 about
and magog also has found is at the
zekiel 37 pastor ross think Ezekiel 37
and 38 talk about gog and magog but it
depicts some of the same scenes where
these enemies of God surround the city
of God and there's a you know a great
white throne judgment and ultimately
fire comes down from God out of heaven
forms a great lake of fire and and all
the wicked are punished according to
what they desert I think you the
parallel passages in the Old Testament
Ezekiel chapter 38 3 but gog and magog
yeah the destruction that comes yeah so
and that's at the conclusion of the
1,000 years it says the rest of the dead
do not live until the thousand years
were finished well if the dead in Christ
rise first the rest of the Dead or the
wicked you get the dead in Christ it's
the righteous rest of the Dead is
everybody who isn't saved that's the
lost they come forth at the end of the
1,000 years and when they realize
they're permanently doomed Satan tries
to rally them to a final assault on the
City of God and that's when judgment
happens in punishment so you know we
have we have a study guide we can send
you on that for free and it's god it's
cold
that's all right go ahead can I say
something
yeah we're told that some will I will
live on for a number of days so it
sounds like they don't die instantly
deleted yeah does talk about yeah it
says that speaking more particularly
about the devil it's it talks about day
and night
how long individuals will suffer varies
because the Bible tells us that each man
is rewarded according to his work but
you know we're in that group of
Protestants we do believe in hell and
the lake of fire we don't believe that
people are going to burn for zillions of
years for the sins of one lifetime it's
longer than zillions some people believe
they're gonna burn forever and ever and
the Bible tells us there is going to
come a world where there's no more pain
no more death no more sorrow all things
are made new and so we see that
ultimately it says the wicked are burned
up that's malachi chapter 4 and though
we do have a study guide i was going to
tell you about the subject of the
millennium and that title is thousand
years apiece the number is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask the static
guide called a thousand years of peace
you can actually read that study guide
for free online as well anacs quality is
donna listening in california Donna
welcome to the program
thank you I appreciate you taking my
call
my question deals with the book of
Revelation chapter 14 verse 9 through 11
what I'm wanting to know is who is gonna
have to be present to during the
destruction of the wicked basically
because what I'm reading here in chapter
10 is that it's only gonna be the holy
angels and the Lamb
that'll be present so I'm hoping it
means that we won't have to watch this
well you know I I don't know how close
our seats will be but you've got you
know obviously the wicked are being
punished after the second coming of the
Resurrection and since we are with Jesus
and we are being gathered by the Angels
I think it's understood that we're still
in the neighborhood when this happens
because it does say the presence of the
Lamb and the holy angels but you know I
think that you know if you don't know
destruction of the wicked that occurs
that the second coming of Christ if you
read the sequence given in the Bible I
don't think our focus is going to be
much on what's happening on the earth
when Jesus comes our prime focus will be
up in the air we'll be looking out
Christ will be on the cloud the angels
will be there we'll be caught up there
will be a glorious resurrection and
loved ones will meet again
so the real focus for the redeemed is
not gonna be what's happening behind
them not gonna be looking over their
shoulder they're gonna be looking up
into the air and they're gonna be caught
up to meet Jesus in the air there'll be
a glorious event it'll be sort of the
climax of the history human histories
when Jesus comes the response of the
wicked Revelation chapter 6 says they
turn to the rocks and mountains and say
fall on us and hide us from the face
behind that's
on the throne and from the wrath of the
land the great day of his wrath has come
who shall be able to stand so the record
our agreement here yeah this torment and
torture that happens at the same time as
the righteous are being raised this is a
part of that all there's two
destructions of the wicked you have the
first destruction that occurs when Jesus
comes but that's the living wicked the
living wicked yeah and then at the end
of the 1000 years you have what the
Bible calls the great white throne
judgment that you read about in
Revelation chapter 20 where all the
wicked are resurrected for the final
judgment then they mount this last
effort to try and attack the golden city
the New Jerusalem and revelation says
fire comes and devours them so the
righteous will be inside the city
they'll be safe but the wicked are
outside the city and they're consumed by
the fire now there is a verse where you
read in Luke chapter 13 28 where he says
you know they'll be weeping and gnashing
of teeth when you see Abraham Isaac and
Jacob and all the prophets all the saved
in the kingdom of God and yourselves
thrusts out so it does seem that there's
at least a brief point where the saved
are gonna see who he's saved and the
loss are gonna see who's lost and and
there's gonna be a very sobering moment
at that time and I believe she'd also
enjoyed the study guide you mentioned on
the Millenium a thousand years yes we
have a study guide on the judgment to
write both of them would be good and
they deal with the subject revelation 20
just call and ask for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace and
your damned horse and that to you and
also your day in court I believe is what
it's called I think that might be the
name of the book but we can send that as
well
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
we're gonna go to our next caller who is
listening in Washington we have Lee Lee
welcome to the program
hi again can you guys hear me again okay
so my question is the Bible teaches us
that we should love our enemies does
that mean that God still loves and have
compassion for Satan who is our ultimate
enemy well that's a good question you
know the Bible says God is love I don't
think that God stops being loved even
though that the devil has rebelled you
keep in mind a parent might have a child
that turns into a real rebel but that
doesn't mean that the parent stops
loving them even if there's thrown in
jail on death row and so I don't know
that God stops being loved the Lord
doesn't like what Satan has become which
is he's become consummate selfishness
and evil but we're not being encouraged
to love the devil when he says love your
enemies I think that the love that we
have for our enemies is you know Jesus
his love broke people's hearts and
converted them the devil is never going
to be converted he's never going to
repent and so I don't think we ought to
waste that kind of affection for him his
Doom is sealed but yeah I don't if it
whether God stops loving there's a
different question and it's yeah it's
hard for us to comprehend but he is a
God of love but there's no no salvation
for the devil Thank You Lee we turned
your volume down a little bit because we
had some background sound effects and
did that answer your question yes all
right thank you and we do have a study
guy that says did God create a devil and
it talks a little bit about that subject
to receive that just call our resource
phone line that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask to the study guide called did
God create a devil and next holy is
Orlando or it is somebody calling from
Orlando I'm not quite sure or land are
you on the air all right well the reason
we had asked that is believe it or not
passed today and I know a pastor who
lives in Orlando and he's first name is
Orlando yes because as a New Testament
believer we'll always
you know Jesus is the only way to the
Father the only way to go to heaven and
my question is does it was you know when
with Noah's day and Noah you know the
Bible says he was a preacher of
righteousness and of course we know you
know he built the ark and this and that
and I'm just wondering what was Noah
preaching back in that day we talked
about this on Sunday school this morning
and the pastor really didn't have a
defined answer as far as you know what
there's no sermon recorded of what he
was you know saying he gave some kind of
there's a Hebrews reference about Noah
but I mean what was Noah preaching and I
find it odd that there was only you know
Noah saved his family on the boat and
you know we don't know how many people
were there but I would just think there
would been some stragglers that came on
the boat you know just out of curiosity
but there was only eight people and I'm
just wondering what the message was yeah
the you know that was preaching good
question well he's called a preacher of
righteousness and the Bible says of
course Noah found grace keep in mind it
tells us one of the first things Noah
did when he got off the ark is he
offered sacrifice even the people who
live before the flood understood those
sacrifices pointed to the day when God's
son would come that's why John the
Baptist said behold the lamb of God
taking it takes away the sin of the
world so he was saying that you know
there could be forgiveness for their
sins they had to get on the boat and
repent you know we have a little bit of
an idea of what Enoch was preaching you
actually finally in the book of Jude
it's the book just before the book of
Revelation
Jude chapter 1 verse 14 says now Noah
the seventh from Adam prophesied about
those not saying sorry Enoch yeah he
says no no I'm sorry well they live it
at the same time they were yeah yeah so
Enoch was a preacher of righteousness
that's right and what did he say well
that's too bad I was excited to share
this yeah wasn't this well nobody said
you know anyway it's a good question
behold the Lord count they they got
saved by just knowing the glory of God
you know just in creation itself before
Christ well they were saved by grace
yeah even in the Old Testament because
God had talked to Adam face-to-face in
the Old Testament they understood the
plan of salvation you
reading revelation it talks about the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world and when Adam and Eve sinned they
tried to cover their nakedness with fig
leaves and God said no it's gonna
require a skin and that's when the
sacrificial system was introduced the
Bible says Abel believed in the blood of
the Lamb and you can read about that in
Hebrews that Abel you know he he trusted
in the blood of the Lamb Cain didn't
want to you know believe in the
sacrifice that pointed to the Son of God
so even these guys that live before the
flood they were saved
looking forward in faith to the
sacrifice of Jesus they were saved by
grace
nobody saved by works we're saved in you
know we've got a better understanding
because Jesus finally came so we're
saved by faith looking back but everyone
is saved by faith a very good question I
appreciate that so much
and I'm trying to think what we have on
that oh you got last night on earth
where talks about Lot's wife yeah
they're gonna be a good book talks about
the time of Noah - and I'm gonna call
he's eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the last day on earth an
ex-police Rebecca listening from
Michigan Rebecca welcome to the program
if I meet you sir likewise and your
question thank ya I have a question I'm
dealing I have low self-esteem and I
need some help to deal with this
biblically alright well first of all if
you want to know better what you are
worth I just did a message on what a
soul is worth and and one of the ways
you determine what something's worth is
by what a person is willing to pay they
say it's worth whatever someone will pay
and what did someone pay for your soul
but God so loved you that He gave His
Son which means that that's the most
valuable price that anybody's ever paid
for anything is the creator himself gave
himself to redeem you now sometimes when
we say self-esteem we've got to be
careful because you know God certainly
wants us to understand our self-worth
but you don't want to be so
self-conscious that it then turns into
pride and your selfishness were you
preoccupied with what your worth is
there's two dangers you get one who
doesn't think they're worth anything and
when something we think they're worth
two
it's so there's a balance there for the
Christian you know when we're crucified
with Christ we don't worry all the time
about what other people think of us
because we know what God thinks of us so
sometimes low self-esteem is because
we're so concerned about what others
think of us and we don't think we're
worth a lot to them but when we know
what we're worth to God that's I think
it gives you the best balance and
centering emotionally and the only one
that we're really concerned about is
what does God care and what does he
think of us but yeah we really
appreciate your question and hope that
helps a little bit I think we may have
is Teresa Lesley in Alabama Teresa
welcome to the program Teresa you there
yes I'm here you're on oh hey thanks for
calling oh you're welcome
my sister was is it biblical to ties off
of your painting well if you get yeah if
you're if you have earned a pension
through your work over the years that
when you when you get a percentage back
you know why wouldn't you want to pay a
tithe on the increase I mean I have been
I just wonder is it biblical Joe because
I didn't know where it was in the Bible
but I know it was an income coming in
well now let me just well it varies from
one employer to another how the pension
fund is built some government pensions
you don't ever really you work two years
and you can get a 40-year pension that's
an exaggeration but other people the
pension money is money that you've taken
out of your paycheck every pay period
and you've already basically paid tithes
on it because it's if you're paint on
the gross income it's your money that
you're putting into a fund sometimes the
employers add to it which would be new
money and then you'd want to pay tithes
on that so it could get complicated but
to keep it simple I just find you can't
outgive God and God says prove me see if
I don't open the windows of heaven and
pour out a blessing take care of you so
I think whenever you're in doubt do the
faithful thing okay thank you
all right thanks and we do have a study
guide will send you for free
on the subject of tithe and it's called
In God We Trust you'll really enjoy it
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the study
guide called In God We Trust my next
call e is louis listening in washington
louis welcome to the program hi good
evening potters evening and this Louis
right Louis yes we oh and your question
to Mexican named banks
my question is about the Feast I've been
studying with some people to keep the
feasts and they bring this passage to me
I cannot remember right now but Paul
uses this he says I'm going back to
Jerusalem for the feast why is he saying
that and is this one of the feast the
same ones that are Moses command yeah
well now Paul is going back to Jerusalem
during the time of a Jewish feast he
wasn't doing that because he was
requiring all Christians to keep the
feasts paul says clearly i have become
all things to all men that i might bring
some to Christ Paul says to the Jews I
became as under the law that I might
reach those who are under the law in
other words Paul said look in order to
relate to the Jews I'm gonna go back and
I'm gonna observe the feasts and I'm
gonna try and meet them on their ground
he wasn't saying that everybody now
needed to keep the feasts because other
places like Romans 14 and Colossians
chapter 2 Paul is very clear he says you
know one man regards one day above
another another man regards every day
alike and he says don't let anyone judge
you regarding the the Sabbath days that
are shadows of things to come
in Galatians he talks about circumcision
and the clear out I mean it's just that
they use the passage and I'm like yeah
Paul is just stating I don't know well
that would be you know I was in the
Philippines and on Easter I went to a
festival to videotape something well my
going there didn't mean that I believed
or agreed with the festival so by Paul
saying I'm going to celebrate this feast
with them well when he was a Jew growing
up that's what he did and now he's
trying to reach his Jewish
and family and so it just states it as a
fact I think Paul also realized this was
a great evangelistic opportunity you had
Jews traveling from across the Roman
Empire mm-hmm just come to Jerusalem for
these special feasts
what an opportunity to share with them
about Christ and revé Angela's 'm yeah
it you know we do have a book release
that talks about the feasts and it's
called feast days and Sabbath's and I've
just written a new book cuz we got so
many questions on the feasts and it
should be in print pretty quick here
because it's all done and it's called
should a Christian keep the feasts
should a Christian keep the feasts so
you call amazing facts and I think we
can send you a copy of that the next
caller that we have is Tom listening
from South Carolina Tom welcome to the
program hey thank you
howdy Doug how you doing tonight I'm
doing good howdy to you too and your
question tonight good to hear from you
singing lots of times in Judah leska Oh
bless you heard yeah I can't meet him
there it's a beautiful place sir yes sir
wanna ask you a question and I'll leave
you alone I've read in the Bible where
that it talks about and I don't know the
passage Doug promised where it talks
about the grapes and fruit in heaven is
going to be tremendously bigger yeah
well that is actually assumed and some
people look at the story where the the
the thieves go to not the thieves so I'm
sorry the spies the 12 spies go and they
look at the promised land and they come
back and the grapes are huge and that we
assume other fruits were very big and
some have speculated that means that you
know in heaven if the if you've got the
gates made of a single pearl and if it
tells us that Josh when Caleb brought
back these huge clusters of grapes how
much bigger will the fruit be in heaven
I don't think pastor Ross there's a
verse that says the size of the fruit
it's just in heaven yeah you know
different food trees yeah it says well
every man will plant eat from his own
vineyard in his own fruit tree but
doesn't talk about the size of it but I
think it's safe to assume if they were
that big in the promised land that in
the heavenly promised land they'll be
bigger still
so yeah good question I tell you what if
if I'm wrong when you get to heaven I
promise that I'll apologize but I I can
almost guarantee you come to my house
and there'll be some pretty big grapes
we're gonna call it free Mexico today we
have is Peter listening in Connecticut
Peter often to the program yeah hey
Peter you're on the air and I think we
got about three minutes yeah uh my
question is a quick twist and um I know
more the God had it but I just can't
find the Trinity inside the Bible and
they have no Twitter yeah well you're
not gonna find the word Trinity you're
not gonna find the word millennium in
the Bible a matter of fact you don't
find the word Bible in the Bible
Trinity's just a theological term that
means try are three like a tricycles got
three wheels entities it's the three
persons of the Godhead nothing wrong
with the term in the Bible it talks
about God's eternal Godhead and but the
the teaching of the three persons of the
Godhead the Father Son and spirit is
found throughout the Bible from creation
where God says let us make man in our
image to the baptism where you see God
the Father in heaven God the Son is in
the water and God the spirit is coming
down like a dove and Jesus says baptize
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Spirit and there's a number of
verses matter of fact there's a book
we'll send you a free copy and it's
called the Trinity is it biblical
I want to put much weight on the word
Trinity that's just the descriptive term
but they're the teaching of the three
persons of the Godhead I believe that is
biblical and we'll send you a free copy
of that book if you just ask the number
to call is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book called the Trinity it's a
biblical we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks well pastor
day we're looking at the engineer over
there on the other side of the glass
we're wondering how much time we have
looks like we have a minute it might not
be enough time for us to take another
caller we'll probably end up cutting
their call short but you did mention a
website on the break and we just want to
repeat that one more time if there were
those who joined us just a great website
for those who want to study the Bible in
depth in particular the time periods
that we read about in the Bible
yeah it's fascinating it's got
illustrations you can click on the
different Bible characters a little
windows pop up to get more information
tells when they were born when they died
is you know some that are question marks
but you'll be able to see how their
lives overlapped see that Samson lived
just a little while before David and
just helps you realize who their heroes
were and and the the time scale it's
called Bible history.com Bible history
calm we know you'll enjoy that your
friends if we didn't get your call this
week God willing we'll be back next week
and we'd love to hear from you i mazing
fax dot o-r-g
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control well you're
hit with something new your marriage
your job your health you could look to
the stars
but they don't know the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
it's 27 personal study guides leave you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vor
G if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF AG 0
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore comm
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at $887 may sing fax 0
RG